I'm not particularly impressed by what
he's done I get called a pimple law but
I and the reason I use the term is
because I don't see it as a negative
term I see it as positively
inspirational and motivating person no
but that's what he did that's what he
did not pimps electronic and otherwise
are the lowest form of life my Mo was
fine girls make them love me and make
them work for me I use sex as a tool to
make women love me so they'd obey me and
live in my house and make me money I had
these guys selling their houses life
savings loans all of it to me give me it
all I was all about trying to get paid
so seems like a lot of conservatives are
turning on the Tates and the red pill in
general what are you charged with that's
a really good question I'm charged with
being the head of an organized criminal
Group which is in charge of recruiting
girls to make Tick Tock videos they face
charges which include human trafficking
and forming a criminal gang to sexually
exploit only fans is the best hustle in
the world are they accusing you of using
violence or no
they're accusing me of using the
Loverboy method coercing them by being
nice I don't mention webcam
until after I've had sex with the girl
if you're on dates and you're trying to
mention it and it just doesn't work
it puts them off I'd never do that
that's disgusting I'm not a uh
it's just not gonna work
you continue as normal no mention of
webcam you the girl after you
the girl you do the PHD test so yeah on
corporate.com I have my PhD program and
that is uh PhD is a Pimpin hoe's degree
that I'm
um
that teaches basically how I got girls
how I met girls how I got girls to like
me how I got girls to fall in love with
me to work on webcam for me uh you're
always working why don't you work for me
so we spend more time together work for
you doing what so you'll have a webcam
business oh I don't want to do that it's
okay I know you don't want to do that
but listen come let's have a meeting
let's just talk about it we don't want
to do it don't do it do it let me
explain it to you properly in fact I'll
bring one of the girls who works for me
your Bolton is the one who does
the selling you don't do the selling the
girl has to hear from a girl and this is
where your Bolton has to be
trained so I said it's so important to
have a good first girl because that's
what I did that was my my Mo was fine
girls make them love me and make them
work for me this girl's like okay well
I'll try it put both girls on camera
together in the first day so the new
girl could sit there and just sit with
the other girl and get drunk give him a
bowl of vodka last night that I worked
for him and you bought me like five
bottles of wine so I got completely
drunk because I've never done webcam
work so I was very very nervous and
that's how I got rich so that teaches
everything I know from start to finish
about uh not only getting girls not only
obtaining them but retaining them
because that's a completely different
game as well and over time I just build
up this big this big little what Empire
of webcam girls at one one point I had
four locations 75 girls working for me
I'd take around half of the money around
50 takes 50 around 50 they thought they
were on fifty percent
and I said that the disparity was
because of taxes he would just pay me a
flat fee of 15 pounds an hour we got to
the point where these guys falling in
love with my models serious big time in
love right send in Crazy money and they
were convinced they were going to meet
the chick this is almost where I kind of
felt bad because they're like can we
meet I've sent you 200 000 I had these
guys selling their houses life savings
loans all of it to me give me it all I
was all about trying to get
kills me that these guys are now the
advocates for men and like men suffering
and all this stuff yeah but they just
made their empire of money on stealing
from Lonely depressed men yeah it just
kills me the irony is so muah
it's like hey lonely pathetic man I'm
Gonna Save you but I also made all my
money by taking advantage of you it's
just so beautiful I'm gonna set it up so
that I'm gonna create this thing with
these girls yeah and I'm gonna take your
money then I'm gonna turn around and
take your money by making you hate these
girls yes yeah
it's crazy
and it's the man saying yo I burn
preacher Sims and this and that and
rooting for this
you got double dipped yeah because now
he's going on conservative it's like
also talk about how bad prawn is and I'm
like bro you made all of your fortune on
Prom all the cars why are you sitting
here acting different yeah you read a
webcam business like my whole I use sex
as a tool to make women love me so
they'd obey me and live in my house and
make me money that that's what I wanted
so I was a pimp in that sense
you're saying I never did those things
but you said that I'm advisor even I
haven't seen some of these videos
ah yeah yeah
take this dude do some traffic
I mean based off what he said himself
that's why I believe it here's the thing
I don't believe somebody can run an
Empire with 75 different women all these
different locations bottom all
these enforcers and there was never no
violence from what I saw from them
WhatsApp messages that were clearly
threads of honest and clearly a bunch of
women who didn't want to be there so I'm
just saying what I've seen it doesn't
make me believe that this dude was
kosher and kind no he even sells himself
I use sex to manipulate them I was
basically coercing them lying to them
about how much they get paid and
stealing their money this dude did
everything Shady Under the Sun admits to
it on his own videos by self snitching
and now wants to claim that I do nothing
wrong I'm a great person maybe you are a
much better man today but the that
you did in the past is still there were
there any other instances where there
was physical abuse I saw him
smack girls with a belt some ideas I've
seen this one yeah this is the one that
I didn't believe because the girl came
on camera and said it was just BDSM
stuff listen if she said it then I'm
gonna just let that go and move it by
the wayside I wouldn't call this against
him personally I'm not
what would you say impressed by what
he's done on the
sex business front it it seems to me a
bit on uh
pimpy side let's say I get called a pimp
a lot but I and the reason I use the
term is because I don't see it as a
negative term I see it as positively
inspirational and motivating person
that's what he did that's what he did no
that's what he did nah p-i-m-p
[Music]
that is maybe the most cringe
nah nah it's like when the girls
talk about crystals and
astrology that's on that level of cringe
oh no I'm not no no it's the the
I'm a babe in total control
of herself yeah
yeah fresh my man's 28 going on 80 and I
don't want that to be you guys and
that's why today's sponsor t.h Henley is
coming in to save the day I get
compliments on my skin all the time
people be asking what's your skin care
routine how do you get your skin and for
a lot of fellas talking about skin care
is a little bit awkward because either
we're too ashamed to do it or it seems a
little bit too feminine but the truth is
having rough skin or having all these
little dents everywhere isn't some that
you necessarily want especially if it's
things that you can easily avoid through
very very good products I recommend
going through that process and that's
where TJ Hanley comes in they got a
great system in place where you can use
their products to achieve your skin care
goals I personally recommend that you
start with the level one system which
comes with all the basics a daily face
watch which gets rid of all the dirt and
Grime on your face then got it two times
per week exfoliating scrub to get rid of
all the dead skin cells and an AM
moisturizer with SPF 20 because we all
need to make sure that our skin is
protected from the Sun and the cool
thing about Tisha all their boxes come
with instructions in addition to amazing
skin members of th handling get tons of
benefits like 20 off retail price the
ability to pause or cancel at any time
as well as free U.S shipping if you
click on the link below you will not
only save 30 percent of your first box
but you will also receive a gift get it
it's uncomplicated skin care routine for
men that's what I use look at this
flawless that shit's nice compared to
this morning you could do a before and
after pimp positively inspirational
motivating person they're accusing me of
using the Loverboy method coercing them
by being nice let me read you then what
you have said about what you have done
sure you have said my job was to meet a
girl go on a few dates sleep with her
get her to fall in love with me to the
point where she'd do anything I say and
then get her on webcam so we could
become rich together I don't think
that's what I personally said I think
that's exactly what you said on your
website that's no I've never said that
nah nah bro if you got that on your
website you try to pretend like you
don't own the website afterwards did he
say that I don't remember he's on my
website but he advertises the website
afterwards it's just so crazy the way
he's trying to switch her out and I
understand because legally his life is
on the line so he wants to disassociate
himself with a lot of them has passed
right he's made his money from this
x-trade he's exploited these people now
he wants to walk away scot-free with his
money which I understand any good
criminal who's made a lot of money would
want to be able to do that but if you're
being honest this man did that and
he said that stuff and it's okay you got
to own it tips on raising daughters so
they don't end up 304s prostitutes on
the poll only fans Etc most men I know
don't have daughters for these reasons
I'll chime in very quickly and I'll say
one I have recruited I think although
you've worked with a lot more girls into
I guess the adult entertainment industry
than anyone else I really have and the
one type of girl I couldn't recruit were
girls with Rich parents oh do that for
money I don't need money my family's
rich so when I see these broke Boys on
Twitter and on Instagram you're like oh
my daughter I'm raising her right and
she's like nine years old but he like
Works some crappy job he's a wagy I'm
like
ah she wants she's gonna get that Louis
Vuitton purse one way or another so you
might want to level up your game and buy
it for my G so since that video has gone
viral a bunch of people seen this video
now and have some things to say one of
them being even Jordan Peterson who came
out he was not holding back let me pull
this up in response to Andrew Tate
in the recent video he says pimps
electronic and otherwise are the lowest
form of life
and people were like no no no I mean
you're not far off the truth listen I
don't know when this happened or maybe
this is a recent day but people are
romanticizing pimping like it's a cool
thing no pimps and what they do to these
women is rarely good and very few of
these women come back from that life a
lot of them fall completely by the
wayside to addiction or they end up
dying shorter lives by becoming street
prostitutes afterwards but it's hard to
come back from being in those kinds of
situations they destroy human life so
anybody want to sit here talking about
how pimps should know don't even try to
sell me on that pimps are some of
the lowest forms of life and I'm not
even mad at anybody wants to say that
how do you feel about pimps you a big
fan no I'm not a fan
no I'm not a fan how do we using bottom
and stuff like that to get other
girls and you know some of the girls
were very impressed and after that what
they go through and yeah no not
impressed some people on the right
myself included have always been a
little skeptical of the guy and pointed
out that he's literally a pimp and
that's not great that's not very
conducive to Virtue so Andrew Tate sat
down with Tucker Carlson to insist that
he's not really a pimp and my Friendly's
wheeler over there juxtaposed his
interview with Tucker with other things
that he has said openly on camera and
makes it seem as though either Andrew
Tate is suffering from a very serious
bout of Amnesia or he lied to Tucker
look man I never seduced women and and
manipulated them into working for me I
that's what they're accusing me of but
that isn't that so crazy and then as Liz
points out he said many times publicly
that this is exactly what he did the
best defense which he sometimes makes
though recently has been trying not to
make is that he didn't the girls he just
seduced them you know what's so funny
about that line of thinking too is like
when you think about the fact that this
guy would joke about them being 15 16
but like oftentimes they were young 18
19 year olds and as a grown man seducing
like such young impressionable Minds to
not only fall in love with you it's like
I think it's one thing if you a grown
ass man if you want to make these women
fall in love with you and then you want
to marry them okay
uh you know
a 12 year age a difference you want to
do that for your life that's fine but
turning them into sex workers when
they're that young and impressionable me
is very slimy behave and the reason why
you go for these young women is because
you know they're so malleable and you
can take over their minds and then
that's why you do it right not only
because of their virtue their youth but
also because you know they're malleable
right so when you're using it for your
own self-interest to make that it makes
it makes it an extra level of slime that
predator in the jungle is not going to
go like oh that animal looks bigger
than me yeah you know what I mean it's
gonna go from smaller animals no that
looks like a prey no then that's what he
I believe that's what he did but then
again that's what I believe that's what
he did because that's what he said he
did
that's the only reason why if you never
put out those videos I wouldn't have any
proof but he said he did those things
it's like
I don't have much to say like he said
that I think a lot of people don't care
because it's women on the other end
suffering one and two it's women who did
Sex work yeah and so for a lot of people
once they see that they instantly start
judging them and say they're less than
human right they don't give a which
is fair you want to think that way
that's your choice to think that way but
I would say how many of these women
would have become that if it wasn't for
this guy he says it himself every girl
that he hired had never done this lineup
work before
and they only did it because he said he
made them fall in love with him
so this guy's creating the very kind of
women you don't like and then you guys
are therefore on them for
becoming those kinds of women
just saying if you hate those women for
what they do you should hate him just as
much for making them and he's but no you
want to praise him because deep down
inside I think a lot of people who hate
these sex workers also deep down inside
want to be with them in different
circumstances man the proof is whenever
they go to different podcasts you
on them but then subscribe to their only
fans yup that's why I don't like this
stuff me I'm perfectly fine with
conservative people who want nothing to
do with sex work and nothing to do with
Andrew Tate I think that's a perfectly
fine thing to do based off the
consistency of your morals but people
who on these sex workers but also
prop up the kind of man who made them
I just don't get that in my personal
opinion and I think it's good that
conservatives are are distancing
themselves from because they just look
like clowns when they want to talk about
oh abortion's bad sex works is bad this
is that but then at this time like the
person that they're hailing as a hero is
a self-admitted pimp really
that's who
someone who manipulates
scams
I think it's a bit weird to have those
two things juxtaposed but that's just my
opinion anything else
foreign
positively impacting manipulating people
apparently or whatever it is
he really thought he did something
he really thought he really thought the
most influential man in the world in my
Bugatti he's like okay bro how many
times you're gonna repeat you're the
most influential man in the world
100 every interview